like to welcome you to tonight's opening
class we're going to go over the Evans
gambit it's a double King pawn opening
it's one of the basic gambit
it used to be very popular in the early
part of the ninth of this of the 20th
century and the 18th century but it's
not so popular anymore but you need to
know how to diffuse it to play against
it because if I you play on the Internet
and someone plays it against you if you
don't have any idea what to do you'll
probably lose very quickly a lot of the
gambits that white can play are tricky
and if you don't know have any idea what
to do you often lose quickly but the way
to defuse them isn't that hard to learn
it's pretty much seen that some
grandmasters how they handle it
for black how they you can always get an
even game so sometimes when that white
gives up a pawn you can actually get an
ending advantage as black with some
chances to win but some of the gambit
sirs are what they call sound that just
means that for the pawn white gets
enough moves gets enough pieces and
pawns out ahead of black that he can get
a strong enough attack to win his pawn
back
that's called compensation so white
often gets adequate compensation for the
pawn sacrifices the Grandmaster most
grandmasters today don't they only play
a few gambits because chess opening
theory has developed they they have it
published in books and online how you
should play against it and if you know
how to play against it it's actually
easier to get an even game against a
gambit then if white doesn't sacrifice a
pawn so the really good players usually
don't sacrifice a pawn like they used to
a hundred years ago but it's part of the
learning curve and it's important for
young and new players to see these
gambits and learn the main idea how to
diffuse it the Evans gambit is named
after an English sea captain who
invented it sometime around 1850 I'm not
sure when but it was played a long time
ago and it starts out like oh we're
going to go through a game by former
world champion Tigran Petrosian and he's
playing another Grandmaster vrl eared sq
they're playing in some little town
called lagina I don't know where that is
European Championship 2013 that must be
a different Petrosian in the world
champion because I thought the world
champion had died but maybe he was still
alive then I'm not sure anyway we'll
jump into it so this is the standard way
to start King pawn openings and when
black blocks your King pawn it's called
double king pawn and then that white
knight comes out that's the preferred
move because you develop a piece at
night and you make a threat against an
undefended pawn and you generally force
black to defend the pawn so white has
the first move advantage and he can keep
that advantage 15 to 25 move
provided he makes aggressive moves and
forces black to defend if white plays
inconsequential moves and some pawn
moves that aren't to the point he lets
black take over as if black had the
first move
then black starts making the threats and
white has to defend so the the first
move advantage and the ability to attack
your opponent is called the initiative
and that's a big advantage that's the
only advantage white has at the start of
the game you need to maintain that as
long as possible
so the trip black does the standard
defense and now White's going to develop
another piece is a king Bishop he puts
it on c4 see how White's pieces and
pawns are all in the four central
squares and the the square around the
four Center squares the four Center
squares are that's the center square
it's the most important squares on the
chessboard the square around the center
squares are called the near center
squares they're the next most important
both sides try to control the center
squares better than their opponent
typically neither side gets total
control now we've only gone let me make
a blacks next move so he brings out his
bishop we've made three moves and you
can see that White's Bishop and pawn
control this square they can both move
here black can't move the pawn up he
would just lose it Black Knight Bishop
and pawn control this square they
prevent this move by white black still
in the defensive white is attacking
black is defending these bishops are
and offset each other white still has
the move advantage he can castle one and
black can't castle yet castling is a
good move another typical move the
bishop comes out and then the pawn comes
up forming a pawn chain you have to get
your Bishop outside your pawns if you
left the bishop here and put the pawn
here you would block the bishop and it
wouldn't have any good squares that
would be passive now you could still get
a draw but you would have given black
the initiative and the advantage of
having the move would move to black
that's the self-imposed bad opening idea
it's totally unnecessary but lots of
players do it another good move for
white is bringing the knight here then
the knight Bishop and pawn control this
square castles is good that's about it
you wouldn't want to move this pawn it
does nothing and there's no reason to
move the rook pawn on the other side
there's the bishop can't even go get out
yet because it's blocked by the pod so
moving a pawn on the side of the board
is a waste of time time in chess there
are three elements in chess forces
that's your pawns and pieces time is you
get you more moves you get your pieces
out faster than your opponent
that's called a time advantage and then
there's a space advantage that's who
controls the most squares now when white
starts out he has a time advantage due
to the first move there's not much space
advantage but you can convert the time
advantage into a space advantage if
can move this pawn up here to the fifth
row driving the night away and then with
the pawn here you've opened up all these
squares behind your two pawns that gives
white a space advantage he can move his
pieces back and forth and make threats
on both sides of the board easier than
black now the idea is that you get
accumulate a time and space advantage
and you attack your opponent and you win
a pawn or a piece that's the material
advantage you need a material advantage
of a pawn you and I might need more than
a pawn but a grandmaster needs a pawn
and he can usually win the game why um
the computers evaluate that as 1.00 upon
is the equivalent to one and that's how
they set the other pieces based off the
pawn being set at one so they figure the
knight and bishop are worth three pawns
the rook five queen nine they don't
value the King because you have to keep
the king if you lose the King it's over
but it's interesting to note that the
King hides in the early part of the game
typically behind these three pawns
because the other guy has his queen
rooks Knight they're trying to checkmate
him but in the ending after you trade
off Lots all your Queens and rooks are
gone and some of the knights and bishops
the King gets bold and moves up and
helps try to win pawns and advance any
past pawns you have to the queening
square in the ending the King according
to the Tarrasch the guy I told you about
is worth more than a bishop or a knight
because the King can go to any color
square and one square in any direction
now a bishop has to stay on one
black or white the night can cover both
squares but they're always alternating
white black white black so the King
actually can push knights and bishops
around unless they're protected by pawns
are the King so now we're get we're at
the point this is called the Italian
game a branch of the Italian game is the
Evans gambit which we're going to jump
into right now and white gives up a pawn
and his you take with the bishop you can
decline you don't have to take the pawn
you can move the bishop back here and
black and get an even game but
aggressive players want to force white
to prove that he gets enough for the
pawn so the preference is to take the
pot now here's where white gets some
time white wants to move this pawn here
but he does that he can't do that right
now because pawn takes he wants to have
this pawn here and this pawn here and
the pawn takes pawn takes he has two
Center pawns and he can shove him at the
knight and force the night away this is
the temple the time he gets for the pod
he moves this pawn here attacking the
bishop with a gain of a move so the
bishops move twice now it moves three
times the best move is to retreat here
we know he's gonna move here if you put
your bishop here you're giving him
another attack on the bishop with the
pawn move if you go here it's protected
by the knight and when this pawn comes
here this pawn the bishop pins this pawn
to the king
so bishop here is the only
good move in this game white plays pawn
to Queen four right away
sometimes they Castle first and they'll
play that the next move they often
transpose together later now what I'm
going to show you is at this point there
are several variations for black I'm
going to show you the soundest move for
black
it's named after world champion Emanuel
Lasker it's last year's defense to the
Evans gambit
his idea was he'll give the pawn back
that white sacrifice but it will lead to
a simplified ending where black has a
small advantage not enough to win but
white will then shift to the defense so
what he does he just protects his pawn
his center pawn now in this game there
are different ways to play this now from
White's point of view we got two games
this game white accepts getting the pawn
back leads to a trade of Queens but he
wins his pawn back he could play more
complicated and that's our second game
this is the traditional last year
defense idea and the other is a more
modern treatment which keeps it more
complicated both games ended in a draw
though okay so white takes now you can't
it's a mistake to do Knight takes
there's a check here I'm the bishop
so you do pawn takes now the Queen's are
opposing each other
the knight protects the pawn and the
knight protects the bishop here's how
white gets his pawn back he trades
Queens now black could take with the
King but then his King stuck in the
middle of the board and he's not safe
and after the knight and bishop or
castles a rook can come here and check
the key so black says I'm not going to
take with the King I'm going to give
this pawn back I'm going to take with
the knight so white gets his pawn back
now it's blacks turn the knight and
bishop are attacking this square but the
knight and King adequately defended but
black has a good developing move he's
going to attack this bishop and stop any
threats by this bishop at night forever
by bringing out his Bishop and his
bishop is defended by the knight so if
the bishop takes the knight takes it's a
completely equal game in fact Black has
better pawn structure see these are
three connected pawns on the Queen side
and white only has two white has a King
side pawn majority with these four pawns
versus three now typically the King of
Castle or it'll move here and here it'll
be on the King side because of that and
the pieces it's harder for white to get
a pass ball and he has to move all four
pawns up and the trade off three and
then he's left with a pawn that would be
a passed pawn black has an easier job
there's only two pawns he only has three
to bring up he'll get his past pawn
before white does that will give black a
slight ending advantage not enough to
win the game but anyway white no longer
has any winning attempts
unless black makes a blunder
well black white doesn't want to trade
the bishops so he chooses to go here
check not a problem
we just advance our pawn and drives the
bishop back so he goes here now he
wouldn't come here because he's
attacking a pawn defended by a pawn he
would have to move back here or here to
do anything so he's going to retreat
this way now he was here he's not gonna
go here and he wouldn't go here cuz this
files open he wants to put a ruck on the
open file and the bishop would block the
rook and he wouldn't go here that's
undeveloped een this is the only move
well Black's going to bring out his
knight and castle so he brings out the
knight now he's attacking this pawn
that's undefended you see the initiative
has passed to black he's making the
threats but white has a perfectly good
way to defend it with moving that pawn
up and black castles white dry it comes
back here with the knight to drive the
bishop back he can't move this Knight
out till the bishops off the pawn so he
needs to drive the bishop back
in this case black chooses to take the
bishop because he didn't want to retreat
his and then he brings up his knight
from the back and white still can't
develop the knight cuz this pawn would
be left so what he's going to do is he
moved his king here he's not going to
castle he's gonna move it here let the
king protect the pawns then he can move
the knight here or here as he desires
and he can move the bishop out first so
black starts advancing his three Queen
side pawns by attacking the bishop white
doesn't want to retreat the bishop he
takes the knight and the pawn takes you
can see it's all it's a very it's coming
a simple game White has a bishop at
night black has a bishop at night to
Brooks and a king white does have a good
center pawn protected by this pawn chain
but it has no attacking value its
defensive it'll stay this way the King
comes here relaxed pieces are better his
bishops out his Knights out white has to
move the King and then he can move the
knight and Bishop out so White's behind
but because the Queen's and other pieces
are gone whites in no danger so he
protects the pawn with the King black
moves his rook to this open file the
knight comes out the bishop drops back
the night might have come here attacking
the bishop he'd have to move it back and
it guard it had now the bishop we can go
on this diagonal but the bishop here
blocked the pawn remember he wants to
move the pawns up so now he's ready to
move the pawn up well well
white-nose these pawns are coming he
plays this pawn here to block the black
pawns now if black plays pawn here white
will not do pawn takes he'll leave this
pawn here blocking this pawn and if pawn
takes he'll take with the rook and the
hricko block of a bond that's a good
defensive setup anyway black is going to
move his knight to a better square
because the knight here it can't go here
here or here and he doesn't want to go
to the side so he's going to come here
then he can come here or here depending
on circumstances white comes here it if
the Black Knight goes here he can trade
knights and get that much closer to a
draw cuz now it's just Bishop versus
Bishop and that's what black does and
that's what white does so we're very
close to a draw now and he's ready to
develop this bishop so he attacks the
rook rook moves up a square now he takes
here takes here and this Rick which is
not doing anything comes over here and a
Texas undefended pawn
you can't play pawn here because this
pawn that rooks unprotected rook takes
pawn and pawn takes rook rook takes four
check we would win upon and probably
wouldn't a game however he moves the
rook over that's an adequate defense the
computer says completely even so we're
getting even closer to a draw there's
five pounds each a bishop each two risks
and a king that's a good move it blocks
the pawns from going here that's the one
danger White has if these pawns create a
passed pawn he brings this king up
attacking the bishop bishop goes all the
way back he didn't want to trade bishops
he can drive this Bishop back with pawn
up and bring that other pawn here
then he could move his Bishop to g7 and
attack this way he just retreats the
bishop now black gets his Queen side
pawns moving but black white can now
trade the bishop okay now rook and pawn
endings are notorious for being drawn
when pawns are even and this is the case
here
so black does pawn up white was
threatening to win this pawn takes takes
rook comes back threatening to win the
pawn the pawn can't advance because rook
takes pawn
he could do check here but work up here
rook takes King takes then the King can
go here and he would lose this pawn so
he can't afford to trade rooks he just
moves the rook up here white moves the
stroke here so there's no check here
black brings this King up so it's close
to the action and it defends this pawn
and there's no check here if the rook
goes off the second row King comes up
attacking the rook the rook moves up
protected by the pawn driving the King
back now the two rooks threaten the pawn
again so black has to go back and they
both this repetition forces and neither
side has a better option so they agreed
to a draw three repetitions is a draw
and you can see there was no way either
side could break through let's run
through the old first few moves of the
opening
so this is the Italian game now the
Italian game they don't sack up on the
main line is here they used to follow up
with pawn here but now they move here
when they move the pawn here it led to
trading pawns and pieces and it became a
quick draw so now they move the pawn
here there are no pawn trades
it's a maneuvering game the game lasts
10 20 moves longer both sides it's more
complicated both sides have chances to
win or lose if both sides play correctly
it's still even modern grandmasters
prefer it though because the old move
with this pawn here after many games
they they knew it was a dry and they
don't want to play draws there's no
point to it okay so the gambit move is
this move sacrificing the pawn and the
bishop takes then they can't take it
would leave this pawn undefended pawn up
fish it back pawn up pawn up takes takes
takes takes got the pawn back Bishop
comes up we're already at a draw in
position black is a little better his
pawns are better on the Queen side white
only has two pawns and they're not
connected they're split so you saw how
he has to bring the King here to defend
the pawn before he can move the knight
out that's adequate but he has no
winning chances now we're going to go to
a more modern game but this was a quick
draw - this was played in 2012 a guy
named Blatt last name at na sure very
strong both
these guys are very strong grandmasters
and again in France I don't know what
country her aunt's from not your sounds
like a German but I'm not sure they're
playing in Germany maybe they're both
Germans Bundesliga Germany in Berlin
someplace in Berlin 2012 okay so again
we get to the key part where the this is
where the Italian games go but the
gambit is here Bishop takes pawn takes
Bishop takes pawn up pawn up now
remember pawn takes pawn takes Queen
takes is the last year method for black
to get a draw it defuses White's
initiative white has a more complicated
way to play he brings his Queen over
here the Queen attacks this pawn and the
threat is Bishop takes pawn check it
forces black to make what looks like an
unusual move unless you've seen it
before he brings his queen up now the
Queen defends the pawn and it also
defends this diagonal because white
could move the pawn here say say the
Queen had gone here the pawn would come
here the knight would go here and check
here would win the bishop with the Queen
here pawn up the knight goes back here
there's no Queen check there's no losing
the bishop and after the pawn comes here
the bishop can retreat and have a nice
diagonal and the bishop would be
protected by these ponds and the knight
here I'll swing over here and come up
this way that would be good for black
well it can go to b5 pinning the queen
but pong up will drive the bishop away
this pawn is protected by a pawn and the
knight and queen so pawn takes pawn
takes the bishop has to retreat that's
good for black it would be a wasted move
by white
in fact pawn up is not a good move for
white white does a better move remember
white wants to attack this pawn up locks
the pond chains they block each other
the black pawns the white pawns block
White's Bishop and queen he wants to
attack he's a pawn down he wants to open
up lines bring a rook to attack the
queen leave this diagonal open and bring
that these knights and bishops out so
that's why he does pawn takes pawn
now if pawn takes pawn see how this
diagonal would be open the bishop would
move here and black couldn't castle now
he could and he couldn't bring the
knight here to block the bishop because
the knight would block the Queen and
allow Bishop takes pawn check so the
right move for black is not to take the
pawn but to retreat the bishop and now
black has a threat of knight here
attacking Queen and Bishop taking the
bishop and then White's attack is gone
and if white does pawn takes pawn
he wouldn't take with the pawn he would
bring his knight out
and if pawn takes pawn he would Castle
and he he might do Queen takes and he's
ready to start a counter-attack with the
knight and the rook and whites Kings in
the middle of the board so white does
not do pawn takes pawn he hurries up and
develops his knight
now black takes the pawn and white moves
the bishop here like I told you so
black can't castle but since this bishop
moved here it freed this square for the
knight and we get the knight fork now
but as Queen here we can't take the
bishop because he's threatening
checkmate well we have to block that
diagonal so we move our pawn up the
Queen retreats now we can take the white
squared bishop
and black has a choice here he makes a
move look at the scoreboard over there
the little black square see the question
mark exclamation mark do you know what
that means it's dubious a good move is
an exclamation mark a bad move is a
question mark a dubious move is a move
that doesn't really help black and black
had a better move but it's not a bad
move he doesn't lose the game or lose
the pawn a black had the chance to have
a slight advantage and he throws it away
with this move it's just even see the
little equal sign after the move that's
what the computer says
this chess based software you
right-click it and you can put the
little symbol that the computer tells
you it's equal that's how you ant put
these signs out you right-click it and
you put the the dubious exclam and in
the equal sign alright now you'll soon
see that this is even here let's see
what black should have done the computer
says he shed this pawn was attacked by
two knights he could have defended it
with that pawn notice that this pawn
move weakens these white squares but
remember our knight took the white
squared bishop so the only piece white
has they can attack white squares of the
Queen the Queen's on a black square also
White's Queen can move over here and
guard the white squares and the bishop
can come up so there's no danger to
weakening the white squares and it's
hoardin for black to defend the center
pawn with a pawn that's the better way
to play now white would get a temple
attacking the Queen the Queen moves up
here then he gets a check but the the
King can't castle he just moves up white
castles now the knight comes out and
White's night either is going after that
rook is going to come here and drive the
knight back the bishop guards this
square as does the knight so there's no
check here he decides to take the bishop
out this is the computer telling us what
to do now now the rook that's behind the
pawn comes out and defends the Queen and
see how the two rooks defend the back
rule they defend each other then white
moves up to the white squares his Queen
here was blocked by the pawn so this is
a better square he just drops his knight
back to a defensive posture Rick comes
up that's a good square see there's no
pawns here so the Rick can go here
protected by the pawn and the Queen
that's a strong square that's called a
hole in Black's position but black
that's the only hole black has and he
can defend it so he brings the ricky'll
where he's just going to trade some
rooks Knight comes back here he wants to
go here and block this pawn and attack
this bishop the King retreats remember
he couldn't castle he moved here the
rook it's almost like he castled that's
called manually castling the King moves
to
safe area behind the night in the ponds
after he got the kick the Rick out the
other white work comes over it is
blocked by the night he takes with the
rook pawn takes driving the Queen back
now White has a passed pawn which is an
advantage in this case that pawn can't
go anywhere the Queen and the night
guard this Square and the rook can come
here that Knights not that pawn is not
going anywhere so it's even bishop comes
up and the bishop comes here see the
bishop queen and Knight our guard this
square that pawns not going anywhere
in fact the Bishop's going to come here
and block the pawn forever then the
knight can go to a more active post he
doesn't need Knight and queen defending
it or it would free up the Queen now the
bishop blocked the Queen from defending
the pawn but why can't take it his
bishops unprotected rook here would
attack the Queen and win the bishop and
then the rook will move here or the pawn
can move here and according to the
computer see the equals over plus in the
black box the top symbol is white equal
the bottom symbol is black plus it's a
small advantage for black if it was a
small advantage for white you'd have the
plus sign on top and the equal sign now
a big advantage would be for black would
be up just not an equal sign a minus
over a plus
for black - over plus equal plus small
advantage about 1/3 of a pawn point 3 3
a big advantage is about 1/2 to 2/3 of a
pawns from 0.5 up to 0.66 you need a
pawn a pawn up to win so a big advantage
is not winning advantage but it's
getting close now a winning advantage
it's not one over the other if it's
white it's plus and then a minus sign so
black is on the right
if black wins it's a minus followed by a
plus sign that's a winning advantage and
it's more than one point like one point
two or something anyway we'll stop here
so white played Knight takes and he
should have brought the pawn up and he
would have kept a slight advantage he
played here and it's completely even it
gives up a pawn so the knight takes the
pawn the other night comes out and
attacks the the pawn that's undefended
Queen comes up check now black has a
choice he can play the bishop and block
the check or the knight he chooses to
block with the knight
Rick comes over but now the pawn move
drives the Queen the Queen's pitting the
night the pawn move will drive the Queen
back and the Queen protects the bishop
as does the knight
now if the Queen went here keeping the
pin the Queen's here so the Queen and
Knight this pawn would fork the Queen
and Knight so this would be a dangerous
place to put the Queen the bishop could
retreat threatening to win this night
Bishop takes Knight Knight takes Queen
takes and there would be the threat upon
here attacking Queen and Knight so Queen
here would be a blunder
he just retreats one squared now there's
no fork black retreats threatening to
win the night this night comes down
check Bishop takes I can't do rook takes
so he has to trade Queens the the black
queen was protecting the Bishop to get
his Bishop back he had to trade Queens
he took the knight and black retreated
here and blacks threat his Bishop takes
Knight
work takes this bishop but then pawn
here the bishops pinned to the King so
he's going to get the piece back he
chose to retreat the bishop now it looks
like he gives up this pawn tonight takes
pawn they agreed to a draw
he doesn't threaten anything his Knight
takes pawn
the bishop protects the pawn
yeah the two bishops give black equality
the pawns are even no whites upon up to
two four but the two bishops give black
equality because they're stronger than
the knight and bishop and he can drive
the knight back with this move so the
knight would have to go here here here
let's say he goes here now this bishop
can come up here and attack this pawn
and he gets strong threats I guess or he
might he might just come over this way
and then bring the rook over but like
you said the two bishops give him
equality so that both players agreed to
a draw so let's run through that one
more time just the opening here's the
gambit pawn up Bishop back pawn up pawn
up now the easiest draws the pawn takes
Trading Queens that goes into an even
ending but black you have to remember
the Queen has to go in front of the
bishop because there's a threat of pawn
here and Queen here check picking up the
undefended bishop so the Queen has to
stay on that diagonal you got to
remember that pawn takes Bishop back
that's a good move it frees the square
up the night here attacks Queen and
Bishop once you get rid of that Bishop
White's attack is gone
Knight out
pawn takes Bishop here
but now we get the night fork Queen up
threatening checkmate so you got to
block it Queen back now you got the
bishop and it's an even game right here
and and black had two ways the he chose
here according to the computer he to
have a slight advantage says he chose
this move rook here here here here here
Knight here Knight takes so according to
the computer that's even
[Music]